The joe rogan experience,
it's going to happen,
but there's always going to be good people that do.
They're always have bins from Amelia Earhart to fill in the blank.
All throughout history has always been women that have figured out a way to
achieve and do things that they really,
truly enjoy doing.
Like our flight attendant,
we got hijacked for the longest time I've ever been hijacked as an adult.
Oh No.
Tommy and I were having a fun little conversation and we ordered a little glass
of wine because were gentlemen and we're on a business trip.
We decided to have a little wine and we're sitting there,
uh,
and the woman came over and she made a joke about the temperature of the wine
and I made the mistake of going,
um,
is it like you're apologizing?
It's too cold.
That's funny.
I've never heard anybody apologize of wine.
It's too cold.
She goes,
whoa.
Well,
if you remember the scene from sideways,
he,
I've never really been much into one.
The only time I drink wine is in church,
but there's a funny thing about wine.
I knew a guy and the guy was a wine connoisseur and they brought him a bottle of
wine and said,
should we put this in the refrigerator?
You strict,
don't you touch it and put it in the refrigerator.
Don't you put a hand on that wine and bringing their voice?
I thought it was so funny,
but of course I don't drink.
The only time I drink it a drunk.
And he went on and on and on.
Yes.
To the point where I was lucky because I was in the window.
So I just abandoned Tommy.
I lifted up the window and I put my face to the glass and then I reached into my
lap,
talk bad.
But I pulled up,
pulled out my notepad and I started writing down and I wrote in my note pad,
the flight attendant won't shut the fuck up.
Yeah,
I wrote that in my notes.
I started writing it in front of her too.
Yes.
Well,
first of all,
she came out when she came over,
she goes,
do you want something to drink?
I said,
yeah.
Um,
do you have Pinot Noir?
Which is not that crazy to say,
no,
we have cab door won't shut the fuck up.
She's like,
this has to be addressed.
When I said,
do you have chemo in war?
She goes,
uh,
excuse me,
and I go,
peanut nor,
she goes,
do you think you're in Leone,
France?
And I was like,
no,
it's not.
Yeah,
it's not crazy.
And she was like,
we got red or white.
And I was like,
all right,
red.
And then when she came back,
it was sideways.
It was the summer.
Yay.
At Macy's,
who when I worked at the hospital,
they brought him the wine and he said,
should I chill this?
And we're talking about the most boring sentences.
Oh yeah,
these were,
these were incredibly boring census.
The worst.
Oh God.
When she left,
when she left and we go like,
what the fuck was that?
She left,
she came back and I just made,
I just looked up.
She goes,
did you ever see the movie Simon [inaudible]?
She was like,
my favorite scene and that has a wine scene.
And I was like,
all right.
She goes and I,
this is when I zoned out,
she was like Bruce Willis and [inaudible] and she was like not all right,
all the wine fall.
I know it's a great scene.
And I was like,
she wouldn't stop.
And you know what's really fascinating before this happened,
before this happened,
Tommy nailed her personality cause we may or may not have had
before we got on that plane.
And so we were uh,
it was just starting to kick in and mid flight and he goes,
you know when I think,
I think that they put her on this small plane because she can't work well with
others and that the other students is don't like working with her.
So they stick her on these small planes cause she doesn't,
she doesn't want to be around anybody.
She's probably been doing this a long time and they know that she doesn't work
well with others.
And then she came over and just right away gave us the ferocious ERBD.
Yes,
it was an ear beating was also,
she gave us an ear beating on church,
shutting off the phones to like everything else about her phone pressing this
button and we didn't have our phones on.
It's not like we were resisting,
we shut our phones off,
but she did it for the whole thing.
Like this is what I want you to do,
right?
You see this button?
I want you to press this button,
not an airplane mode folks,
not an airplane mode.
I want you to shut this button.
If you have an iPhone,
I want you to slide that over the to shut it off.
And I mean,
she's going on and on and on it taking a long ass time.
And if you wanted to read a book or if you wanted to,
you know,
listen to your Ipod,
eh,
that's not happening.
No,
you're dealing with this nonsense you're dealing with and you can't even fight
against that nonsense because if you argue at all about anything,
they kick you off the plane.
Yep.
She's got the power.
I had a friend that kicked off the plane because he was upset that they didn't
find a seat for his son next to him.
Like they didn't find anybody that was willing to move.
It was an hour and a half flight from San Francisco to Seattle.
It's a quick ass flight and they,
you know,
he said,
is there,
is it possible?
She was like,
sir,
we've tried.
There's nothing we can do.
He goes,
I have a five year old though.
Like,
why did you guys sell me a ticket?
I told you it was five years old.
You can't have a five year old sit by himself.
He's,
he's terrified of flying in the first choice.
Like all I'm asking is someone,
if you ask if someone could switch seats,
and she said,
sir,
I've tried.
There's nothing we can do.
Please take your seat.
And he was like,
you guys are the most unfathomably friendly airline.
Like you guys are horrible.
I can't believe you're doing this.
So that's all he says.
He goes and sits down and the fucking captain comes up to him,
said,
sir,
you going to have to come off the same.
They say you're aggressive and you're,
and he was like,
what?
He goes,
you've got to be,
you must be joking.
He goes,
all I asked is if they could find a seat for my son.
I didn't use profanity.
I didn't raise my voice.
I said,
you guys are the most unfairly friendly airline that I've ever seen.
That's all I said,
because you weren't even willing to look for someone.
And they kicked him off the plane and he was like,
I can't believe this.
He goes,
I'm not aggressive.
They,
but we saw that was it.
You and I that saw that?
Who did we see?
We,
we on a plane,
we saw two guys arguing about the,
the been,
um,
I don't know with me on that one,
people kicked out.
It might've been Ra.
I've seen a lady to get kicked off or having attitude,
um,
about like her whole day.
And she was like,
Hey,
you put me later on this shit.
And now me and him talking about it and she was just complaining,
complaining,
and you know,
she was I think aggressive speaking to them.
Boom boot.
And I saw one who got kicked her whole family off and she had small children.
She was breastfeeding one of them.
And they were like,
we're going to taxi now and you need to,
you know,
why did she get kicked off?
She gave the lady attitude about the flight attendant attitude when the flight
attendant asked her,
um,
I don't know if she asked her to stop breastfeeding while we were going to taxi,
but she told her like,
you know,
why don't you just worry about the drinks while I'm breastfeeding?
And they were like,
ah.
And then we stopped and they actually,
that one,
they had police come out to the,
uh,
to the point,
he didn't go back.
The police came out,
they opened the door.
They just get off on the power is absolutely.
I think sometimes,
uh,
I think sometimes they,
they absolutely want to protect themselves and they have to,
you know,
you can't have somebody who's a,
an actual threat right.
The flight,
but I think,
I think there's definitely a thrill and knowing that if somebody gives you kind
of a little jab,
kind of a little attitude,
you can be like,
I could fuck up your day right now.
Yeah,
pretty,
pretty badly and I can justify it.
And we were talking about that,
that this ability to hijack you.
It's kind of the same thing because in a normal scenario,
you don't have to listen to this person.
You're not stuck in a chair,
literally strapped in with a fucking belt.
Yeah.
But you have to listen and then they can just hover over you and just shit in
your face,
your headphones on in your hood and your glasses.
That's why I do that in the middle of a conversation when you're having a
conversation with another guy and then you're having a wine and then all of a
sudden,
boom,
you're stuck.
The glasses,
I don't know if you remember the glasses where these,
they're like tasting glasses.
They weren't very small,
very small.
And the first time I had two sips and his empty and she goes,
you one refill.
And I go,
yeah.
She goes,
oh,
I had a couple of drinkers up here and I was like,
it's Kinda like,
you know,
I can see a certain person,
not me personally,
but I could see that comment really setting somebody off the the outside
implication of like,
wait a couple of drunk.
I don't want to say no,
no,
no need to say anymore than we already said.
We already got to curl.
Poor Lady.
She's lonely and she wants to talk to people.
Jesus Christ,
a couple of assholes.
That's okay.
I feel,
I don't feel right about it,
but don't you think it's an inability to read social cues?
Yes.
Oh,
there's no doubt.
She has no doubt.
Arrow ability.
She wasn't good at it or she didn't care.
She just wanted to talk.
Who knows?
You know,
a lot of people by the way,
are a little pilled up and they don't even know that.
You don't want them to talk to you like there's some every piece.
Everything's going to be okay folks.
Here's a few of those people that are an antidepressant.
The fuck up,
super duper common.
If you look at the number of prescriptions sold,
the number of anti a antidepressant prescriptions that are sold in this country
every year,
it's staggering.
I believe it's like 30 million,
30 million people in it.
Let me see.
Let's see how many people are on antidepressants?
Let's just guess.
I'm saying it's about 30 million.
Yeah.
I think I remember that book.
PROZAC nation was that in the nineties that's when they started it.
It's exploded.
Everyone was on Prozac and such a huge industry.
I know.
I know a handful of people have a friend on PROZAC.
Good guy too.
Great Guy.
Astounding increase in antidepressant use by Americans.
I Harvard University study,
Harvard health publications from Harvard Medical School where you could just
smoke weed,
right.
People 12 and over.
Increased by almost 400%
hmm.
Wow.
Between 1988 to 1994 and then from 2005 to 2008
yeah.
That's incredible.
Holy Shit.
23% of all people on antidepressants are women in their forties and fifties no,
no,
no.
Excuse me.
23% of women in their forties and fifties are on antidepressants.
Menopause for,
yeah,
3% holy shit.
You're going through the change in life,
a higher percentage than any other group by age or sex.
Just stop and think about that.
23% of women in their forties and fifties are on a pill that keeps him happy.
Statistically.
That's a really good chance that our flight attendant is one of those pieces.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Look,
I had a friend that was on it and one of the things he said to me was that when
he was on it,
nothing bothered him.
He was on Zoloft and he's like,
nothing bothers me.
Nothing doesn't conveys me now.
Everything's fine.
Nothing bothers me.
Yeah,
and those kinds of people that they don't,
they don't see things coming,
so they're not aware that they're being weird.
I wonder what it would interesting obviously won't happen,
but to hear what her version of that dialogue would be.
You know what I mean?
It's also kind of like,
it was great talking to those guys.
So much fun.
These two guys in wine.
We had a great conversation.
They love me.
They love my fucking anecdotes about [inaudible].
I told him the sideway story and,
uh,
never seen.
Two guys have a better time and
they were pretty on the end of the fucking bottle.
One of them had two drinks.
The other one had about fine,
maybe a total four ounces.
They were there.
They were,
they were really little glasses.
Spin glass of wine.
Yeah.